буквами пензель би в так малазійських
авіаліній краще заз і управляла весь
кого служба всі 53 зенітно-ракетної
бригади російської армії створилося
обстановкою то експорт не групі банкет
у тому хто самий давши команду запустіть
ракету журналісти-розслідувачі поки що
сказати не можеш то ми пам'ятаємо вона у
глядачів у кози та теплі чо на
фотографіях розмиття тому людина
фонд не раз нормально не men ми змогли
звозить і колов підозрюваних до 20 осипу
без середньої пов'язані з експлуатацію
буком локалізованих вона ми в донецькій
області
теософи з виймання та відомості про
ракетну установку з високою
мобільністю саме серце 20 sep як
мінімум від дена бакелітової канавки в
апараті та всі виставці drupa відео
результат аналізу даних за відкритих
джерел експорт і bellingcat вивчив і
близько тисячі асу швидких сурина шматок з
моря жах зручність та відео експерти
командира дивізіону, що вказує по саду
на ту годину обсягу в будинку витрати
командиром бригади books сергієм уч-до if
a la рішення про саму операцію машина
піну було прийнято на біса високий розуму
ремені поважайте експерти
легенда phone as the super hits ми
поважаємо ще право видного ти покарана ви
просто не загину і ракетної установки
не можна передати і третім особам c
перебуваю compoud антиросійської армії у
нас анни мої прямих доводили я не
можеш вбиваємо це ще путін чеші
купленої мені за голом на хвалив її
засмоктування за ні на вас броня на сході
україни copy of the відношу контакти
експертна група bellingcat вже час
дала результати свого розслідування
нідерландам у варіанті для солідних
казани поза іманом і призом речам і до
зриву на хімічну службу вти в росії
а їхня її блища на фотографіях не розмити
їм на думку аналітики в c та свої рядним
лещатам журналістика кульгати і кістки
спадщині